欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目理财达人秀
我是李兆华
今天是8月的最后一个交易日
整个8月我们涨了3008点
而外资也在8月是大幅的买超
不过今天最后一个交易日外资是转为卖超
其中有一个原因是上个礼拜五
华许说话了
其实听起来跟之前的讲话没有太大的不同
但是现在9月联准会升息一码的几率
飙高到了50几%
这让美股的科技股又产生了压力
那它会不会影响到接下来9月的行情呢
以今天台股的收盘来说
我们还是世界强
盘中有跌到800多点
但尾盘MFCI的季度换股
把它给拉上来
中场只小跌了202点
而今天大家最关心的新兴电子
上个礼拜五有跟大家聊
也许开盘得先走一趟
但是走不掉啊
成交量好小
但盘后筹码
投信不但没有大卖
还反手买
这代表什么意义呢
今天要好好来跟大家做解读咯
来欢迎今天的三位来宾
第一位是股市市工永年老师
好 永年老师
之前就提醒我们这一波台股会反攻
但是滑雪的一席化
让现在九月升息的几率往上跑
往上跑美元可能会转强
外资可能会落跑
我们要不要担心呢
现在师公说首月线就不要太担心
而今天盘面上可以看到
所谓的会不会有新兴电的转单股
有一些PCB是很红的哦
这一些其实长得不只是转单
等一下师公会告诉您
更重要的是手上有新兴电的人
本来早上觉得我卖不掉好痛苦
但盘后一看投信在买
那明天我该怎么做
等一下师公也有独家的看法哦
好第二位是题材猎人汉伟哥
汉伟哥也要讲
今天MSI拉尾盘
里面有一个成分股很重要
叫做记忆体
好我们有全世界最强的南亚科
今天创下收盘高
那其他的记忆体到底能不能跟上来
卡在什么样的条件
等一下浩远哥跟您说分明
因为业绩真的叫做超级好
另外现在苹果光打得亮晶晶的
除了光学股之外
散热板材也有受惠的
尤其是多题材更不怕
等一下来教您选
第三位是我們的冠軍操盤手
雲翔哥雲翔哥今天有大獨家他又參加了比賽淨收益目前達到1億元到底排名到底幾今天會告訴大家他的策略另外看高做低
後來教您
其實SpaceX相關的
現在美股的評價是提升的
台場供應鏈那麼低
有沒有便宜貨可以減
還有就是半導體展
帶您去看
裡面的特化股
已經有人先領頭搖表態
一樣看高做低
還有哪一些潛力股呢
首先有請施工
永年老师
好 没有想到
华许在讲的时候
其实我有听
但是是不是因为
外国人比较听得懂英文
就看到美股扑通跳水
想说怎么了
但是台股今天
其实还好
尾盘还拉起来
那再来的话
很多人都想问
有星星怎么办
网传了很多
PCB有很多的社会股
可是最奇妙的是
今天投信没有大看星星
本来明天想要排队去卖的人
要不要先等一下
是 好 来我们先看一下
这个滑雪它到底讲了什么
让美国股市大跌
其实它只有讲的
真正重要的是一点
这个美国同胞还是高于2%
它我们的目标就是要把
就是你看它还有工作要做
就是要把这个同胞率压到2%
大家一听那就完蛋了嘛
对不对
所以本来的这个预估
他们对这个9月要升息的几率
结果一下子就跳到将近60%了
可是今天来讲
你不要说我们台湾的股市是开机走高
就是留了很长的下影线
你看韩国股市也是开机走高
日本股市也是一样开机走高
所以看起来这个事情
大家也已经有点麻痹了
有点习惯
就伸吧 让它伸这样
对
那就不理它了
好 那么我们看一下月线
月线这个月的月线
刚好收了一个大力光
就是3008
3008是大力光的代号
对
對 就是大力光
那麼其實它這個月能夠收3008點
真的已經很厲害了
為什麼
因為7月份的時候一跌
大家就已經嚇得要死了
會不會反彈一下
然後9月份
現在大家最擔心的9月份
會不會跌得比7月份還慘
我們如果說從這個K線來看的話
那麼我這樣子講好了
這個9月份的它的日均量
要達到1.15兆
如果能夠達到1.15兆的話
它收紅的機會會比較大
如果沒有的話還是什麼八 九千億的話那可能這個要拉回來整理一下這一點可能要注意一下另外我們從日線圖看的話
今天留下了
我記得是600多點的下影線
非常長的一個下影線
而且它守住了所有的移動均線
連這個五日線都守住了
表示怎麼樣
這盤還是非常的強勢
明天非常的重要
為什麼明天呢
理論上來講明天收個紅
应该要收个红
可是万一呢
它明天是收黑
而且把今天下影线吃掉一半
所以简单地讲
它只要
它的明天的跌点
超过350点的话
其实对于多头就比较不利了
因为今天放量
今天有量
然后又留很长下影线
对不对
表示呢
有洗盘成功
对不对
可是呢
明天如果再收黑的话
就表示呢
今天是拉高在出货
尾盘拉高在出货
那这样子反而不好
所以要特别地注意
那月线跟季线是多头
一定要守的地方
那如果守不住的话
那技术面就可能有转弱的机会了
所以稍微的要小心一些
好 再过来我们看台积电
台积电我们上个礼拜就讲了
它在那边做个收链三角形
我们看一下日线
早盘开低
然后一度打得很低
把这个月线 季线全部跌破
然后你注意看
它的所有的短中期的移动圈
全部都纠结在一起了
全部纠结在一起
有什么好处呢
它是极端好或极端坏
为什么
因为它今天还不错
是今天除了五日线之外
它其他的线都守住了
它其实收在最高
而且它只小跌
0.62%而已
没有错
所以它表现其实不错
它明天如果能够再带量
再拉出一根长红的话
那么它所有的移动均线
就有机会一起向上翻扬
那你知道
所有的移动均线
都一起向上翻扬的时候
那个力量是很集中的
它就可以把这个股价推升上去了
过去的三个礼拜
外资其实是在默默的买超了1.5万张
买到不多
可是融资余额也减少了2027张
这一点很重要
因为台积电一直是我们散户的心头好
大家都很喜欢它
所以零股用融资买了一堆
最近这三个礼拜
融資餘額反而減少
盤久了就有沒耐性的人可能不想用融資買他了嘛對 沒有錯 就減少了所以他的筹码面来讲的话反而对多头是比较有利的那我们就等他的一根长红出来
因为他一表态
这个指数就不太一样了
另外就上礼拜五
我们就有提到星星
那再过这个周末的时候
其实案情就有比较明确的进展
原因出来了息产地
而且重点在可能不是载版
是所谓一般的PCB产品
然后又大概15个人被抓去调查
所以到底这个事情严重性到哪里
欣欣也出来讲
就是它是PCB产品
那我们相信它是PCB产品
那PCB的产品对它的业务
到底有多大的影响呢
我们可以看一下
传统PCB呢
它只占它的总业务的
大概9%到11%而已
其实这占比并不是很高
那我们现在就要等消息出来
它到底是是不是
究竟是不是只有传统的BGP
有受到影响
如果是这样的话
那其实真的没有很严重
以业绩来说没有很严重
对 没有很严重
所以你看外资还来送暖
外资不怕我维持买进
那美银不怕我的目标价
还是1400
那瑞银也是一样
我不怕买入的平等
OK 好
那统一投顾的说法呢
它是这样子
是 为什么用统一投顾
是因为婉婷在这儿
是 没错
女王怎麼說
對 沒錯
那它疑似PVC產地
那它這個
跟這個產品跟ABF載板無關
所以影響是可控的
還有這個比較重要
美國客戶不會更換
ABF載板的供應商
或調整訂單比例
為什麼
因為現在每一家的ABF載板的訂單
都滿到一個爆出來了
對不對
誰有辦法去接這個
多出來的單子
都沒有辦法
所以都沒有任何廠
有能力接轉單
所以应该有限
应该有限
可是如果是PCB的话
我这样子讲
或许会有一些急单
短期的急单
它非要出货不可
现在又不能出了
所以它只好去找别人做急单
可是以长期来讲的话
我也觉得影响不会太大
好 所以同意头顾看法说
它对于股价影响应该小于20%
因为它有提到说
之前有美稍微啦群联
它是财报的问题
那個可能事情更加嚴重
那個很嚴重
而這件事情的話
與它的財務影響看來沒有那麼大
所以它是用這樣子
不過股價要怎麼樣走
不是說這樣講就
〔此段辨識失敗，約 10:00 起〕